no probable cause exists to file any
charge against officer Wilson we do have
work to do here
America isn't everything that it could
be when I see the protest in Ferguson I
feel the pain of the citizens it feels
if they're boys doesn't matter whenever
these incidents happen Eric garner in
New York City and certainly Michael
Brown in Ferguson Missouri those
incidents impact our ability to police
in every community in this nation I
think it takes people back to those
feelings of mistrust it definitely had
me reflect on what happened in
Cincinnati and how we felt
[Music]
[Music]
it was one shot fired by the officer the
individual was pronounced dead at the
hospital people who had been abused by
the police decided to take to the
streets there was a problem black
leaders had just had enough and so there
were three days of protesting in the
streets which gave a clearer view to
people who were dragging their feet that
the Cincinnati Police Department needed
to be reformed historically what has
been proven to occur in most of our
inner-city neighborhoods in the country
is that we over police black and
Hispanic neighborhoods but we also
police differently there we have
zero-tolerance models and we have real
aggressive hot spot policing models in
those communities and it's not okay to
throw those young people on the ground
it's not okay to stop and frisk people
who haven't done anything wrong
minorities in the United States never
forget those negative encounters that
they have with police officers
I'm in my 29th year here in the city of
Cincinnati there were really no
candy-coating what was happening in the
city of Cincinnati and how divided our
city was community had been asking for
the Justice Department to come in and
take a look at the police department's
policies and procedures I wasn't here in
2001 but I can tell you from studying
the collaborative agreement and being a
police officer for a long time you know
cops needed to understand here and in
other cities that you have to do
business a different way
[Music]
the role of the monitor is to come in
and to oversee police reform such as how
the police department used force our
trained its officers our disciplined its
officers I remember vividly the
monitoring effort was extremely
difficult
they were extremely antagonistic towards
me and the monitoring team the process
wasn't easy I saw the police department
coming kicking and screaming because we
had done business the way we had done
business for so many years
the default stance that most police
agencies have is big me little you we
tell you what we are going to do to make
your community safer and we're going to
tell you how we're going to do it
I think problem-oriented policing is
just the opposite it is problems that
are organically driven up from the
community and that you strategically
work to improve that situation with
input from community members you know he
looks at
[Music]
our citizens complain Authority gives us
the opportunity to do our own
investigation citizens feel is if they
have issues they have a place to go an
independent body that's not part of the
city will take their complaint and
investigate it each contact with the
citizen whether of the traffic staff
whether it was a field interrogation
stop you had to fill out the contact car
name age race why you were making this
stop and the cry was more paperwork more
work for the police but in the end that
work through that time period helped
assist us to get us to where we are now
complaints started going down so those
cars did help change the mindset of this
interaction with the city so we still do
them absolutely
I'm a member of the quality of life
enhancement team unit this is a lot
different than running a beat because
I'm able to focus on my target area for
my entire shift I'm not getting
dispatched on to different radio runs we
interact with these kids for three
months at a time and we get to know them
by name when stuff happens to them it it
bothers us but it also gives the
community a chance to really trust the
police and see us as individuals and
people rather than just a police officer
that's responding then going off to the
next one need some help
she's right here this one if she did her
surgery and I just get to the roof with
you right she's going in and she's well
he's loopy third floor
you got her she's got her wisdom tooth
pulled
I think policing needs to change in
America I think it needs to be different
with a different focus the relationship
building that police officers have to do
in those communities gives a certain I
call it a relationship collateral if you
will people will allow you to make
mistakes if they know you and they trust
you one of the things that I was most
afraid and we finished monitoring was
could these reforms be sustained
well now we're really six years out and
from everything I can tell there
continues to be good interaction good
communication
I do see some change we're not utopia
yet for african-americans in the police
department we're not there yet
but I'm glad that we started in 2001 I'm
glad of where we are today I look
forward to going to the Missouri's and
the Cleveland's in New York and talking
with everyday people who care so that
everyone is treated fairly that everyone
has an opportunity to fair and unbiased
policing
[Music]